Hi, everyone.
In this lesson, we're going to go and take a look
at all the things that we've talked about so far
and make a quick little environment.
And we're going to look at the concepts and some of the tools
that we've covered up to this point.
And then later on, we'll look at world partition.
And then after this lecture, we'll
also look at lighting and so forth
and how to even make your worlds look even cooler.
So let's get started.
So in Unreal, we went in here
and we messed with some of the tools that we had.
Remember, one of the things I pointed out
was when you are working with Unreal, if you needed to
and your terrain is maybe pretty beefy and pretty large,
you can nanite it.
And that will help with performance
as you set that up, enable nanite.
Now, I'm not going to do it for this particular one,
but that actually can be helpful.
You also want to determine when
you make your terrain, how detailed your geometry is
going to be ahead of time.
And what I mean by that is how close
are you going to get with a camera?
What are the regions that you really want
to make look realistic or not realistic?
You have to keep that in mind.
Now, our terrain is a bit stylized texture wise
and a bit of the shape and our polygons aren't very high.
So all that kind of works pretty well.
But let me show you what I'm talking about.
So if I go into the landscape tool again,
and I go into sculpt and we go in here
and we do some sculpting,
we're just pulling up from the terrain.
We can also load what we want texture wise
for our brush, as well as an alpha.
Those options are pretty helpful.
Now, if you have a really detailed texture
you're using to do some sculpting,
keep in mind that can break down
if your polygons aren't very high.
And you see a few sharp angles right in here
because my terrain isn't highly detailed.
And that can be a problem if you decide
to get in here and say,
hey, I want some realistic hydro erosion
and say, I'll lower my brush size for a second here,
lower that down.
And again, I can also play with the brush fall off
if I needed to and overall tool strength,
iterations and sediment capacity.
All these things are in there as well as rain amount.
So I'll go in here and I'll start sculpting.
But if I go in here and I'm like,
well, my erosion isn't as detailed as I want.
You're going to have to revisit
or even rebuild or load a height map,
whatever it is that you find of a greater value
to be able to get that polygon,
to get that ability to make it have a higher detail,
to be able to get that capture,
that detail for your scene.
Otherwise it might look a little weird.
This came out okay as I'm painting,
you can see it kind of shuffle
through the geometry a little bit,
but at certain angles, it may degrade a little bit,
such as at this corner, you can see that it's sharp
because I don't quite have enough detail
in my geometry as a whole.
So I just want to remind you of that
when working with this tool,
that it's very important to determine what you need
and want ahead of time.
So let me go and increase my brush size here
and let's go and do some sculpting here.
Back to regular sculpting.
We're going to pull up some hills here in the water
to make it a little bit believable for the waterfall.
Now again, if I wanted to,
I can go in here and paint into my environment.
I can create flowers that are nested in here.
I prefer to do this through the foliage only,
but it is built in here through this particular pack
where you can actually do that
and you can paint those flowers
as you're painting your environment.
And you'll see them pop up there.
They're pretty flowers.
All right, so let's go ahead and switch to selection mode.
I'm going to go ahead and grab the blueprint
that I've already created for you guys,
which is this little fellow.
Let's go and pull this over
and this is the waterfall blueprint.
Back here is just simple geometry as a demonstration.
If you wanted to do that,
you don't always have to use terrain.
You can use geometry
and you can even get it so it blends on the edges.
We don't go into that as deep
as we do in our landscape classes,
but in here,
we're just going to keep things fairly simple at first
and we'll dive in a little bit deeper in just a second.
So I'm going to rotate this about 90 degrees.
I'm going to pull this forward
and I have a shader set up in the water
so that it does get a nice foam
wrapping around the rock here.
And I'll pull this up a little bit higher.
Now, remember the nice thing about working with this,
I can go in here and mess with the Niagara.
I can go in here and mess with any static mesh
that I want and need.
So like, hey, what is six?
If I move this around, what does that do?
Oh, hey, that's the ripple effect.
So I have a little ripple shader
if I wanted to pull that into here
to be able to be seen better.
And we can move that down and move that up
and we'll just put him back in there for now
because it's going to take some messing with.
There he goes, hey, camera angle.
He shows up to the party.
They'll just need an adjustment in the shader
but that's just something fancy if you want to play with it.
But I can go in here and mess with the water
if I wanted to.
We can make it go a little bit closer to the rock
so it's less of a shadow.
And so again, you can mess with those individually
and that's a nice thing about the blueprints.
They're all together and they're also separated
in such a way so they're nested
and we can play with it.
Pretty cool.
Looks like my rock's peeking above the water, big deal.
All right, so we'll bring in the windmill.
And again, we can turn this windmill into a blueprint
since they have two pieces together.
And to be able to do that,
we simply just convert to blueprint class.
We'll call this windmill.
Let's put it into the blueprint folder.
There you go.
And we'll call this blueprints windmill.
Oh, two, I'll say windmill, oh, two.
There you go.
And drag this over.
Move this over to our scene.
I don't have the full set in here from this stylized pack
and you can see the stylized pack here.
Call out to the team that has made this.
If you go into our world building for games,
you're gonna see a couple of things.
Asian village from our marketplace
as well as stylized Provenical.
And that's really where this one comes from.
Now the nice thing too is we can actually grab our PCGs.
Now, one thing I wanna mention,
this PCG is a bit different.
If we go and grab this PCG and pull it over,
you'll see that this PCG is built in such a way
and you can see under components there,
you can see under settings off here in the details
and you'll see the instance graph
and that's how you can pull it up.
I know it's not really super intuitive all the time,
but in here, this is using an input landscape.
And that input landscapes allows me to put in
the necessary pieces that I need and wants
and I have a distance and union.
And again, you can do the other approach
that I showed you for the PCG.
But in this case, it just makes it so it's less pruning
and it's identified on this environment.
Now you'll notice it gets a little weird.
You'll notice there's a tree sticking out
to the left here, right?
So that tree could be an issue
and in newer versions of PCG as we're coming,
as it's developing and evolving,
we're gonna have it so you can actually edit these
a little bit easier, rotate them.
It's a little tricky now, but you definitely will have it
so it's a little bit easier to edit those things
when you come across those particular values.
Now, remember in your PCGs at any time,
you can address and swap out.
Let's go full screen for a second.
Any of these trees, any one that you have nested,
you'll notice I have three different ones in here
and I can go in here and mess with his values,
but you'll notice there isn't a whole lot
with rotational control
and we're going to be changing that.
So I'm gonna go and move this over.
You'll notice it's going to adjust the terrain,
which is so nice.
And I'm not using the bio meme.
You definitely can experiment with it,
but remember it is experimental right now.
But say I want to duplicate this.
Oh crap, Sean, I got to build one all over again.
Nope, it's pretty easy.
Keep in front of the alt key,
use the widget move key and bring it over.
And then you have another flock of trees over there.
We have it over just a little bit.
There you go.
Populating the world.
If you want, we can put the house in the back.
Got a little anime wind here
and we want it if we wanted to put it in,
bring the house forward,
kind of clipping into some of this.
Move it back just a bit
and let's flatten our terrain
so this doesn't look so goofy.
So we grab our terrain, go back to landscape.
Let's move into that area a little bit faster.
I'll get out of landscape just for a second.
Select this and hit the F key.
There you go.
Go to landscape and we'll use the smooth tool.
That gives a nice little average for everything.
We don't want to do texturing, we want to do sculpting.
There you go.
Much better.
And do smooth, not lift.
There you go.
Look at that.
Now you'll notice the PCG's adjusting.
I love the fact that it does that.
If I'm changing the terrain
and say I wanted to make this a little bit more hillier,
the PCG is going to adjust.
I just think that's so great.
So helpful, thanks PCG.
You're welcome, Sean.
And we're going to go over here
and we're going to smooth this out a little bit more.
There, it just gives it nice and level.
And if we want to, we can switch back to selection
and we can go in here
and move this according to what we need
and then even change the terrain again
and smooth that area.
And we can also indent it if we wanted to.
So we can go and do sculpt,
keep my finger on the shift key
and push that down.
Just kind of nice.
And look, we got a little puddle.
Oh, that's cute.
Push this down a little bit.
Maybe pull it up a little bit.
There you go.
Pretty neat.
So it's really great to be able to get these things
set up and get going.
The one thing I do want to mention too,
when it comes to sculpting though,
is you do want to be careful
when it comes to such things as erosion.
Like I said before,
you want to be careful of those values
and how you build things out.
But overall, yeah, that's about it.
So hopefully you enjoyed that.
You feel free to jump in here
and grab what you want in the scene,
get them in place the way that you need and want.
And you can play with all these assets.
These are all yours.
You can experiment with it,
make blueprints to your heart,
heart content to your heart's content
and play with these values
and you'll see how quickly you can build a world
and get things set up.
That's it.